Замість села з населенням у понад тисячу осіб тепер руїни...
Це та ще незліченну кількість мін-пелюсток, які й досі
ховаються у траві, по собі залишили російські військові.
Та попри мінну небезпеку й відсутність світла сюди -
у Кам'янку, що неподалік Ізюма -  люди все ж повертаються.
Одними з перших додому повернулися Людмила та Володимир Корнійча.
Щоправда, фізично їхнього дому тоді вже не було.
Тож нині подружжя зводить новий будинок.
Ось на цьому місці в нас була хатинка.
Така гарна, красива.
Ми її утеплювали, робили для неї все, щоб нам подобалось:
теплу підлогу, утеплили стіни, гарні віка поставили.
Нині ж змушені тіснитися в старій літній кухні,
яку вдалося частково відремонтувати після навали росіян.
Одну кімнату ділять разом із батьками
Людмили та усіма котами й собаками.
Я взагалі тут майже не сплю, тому що тут миші.
Оця стеля і плівка - це просто прозорий полігон для мишей.
Вони по ній так ходять. Для цивілізованих людей жити разом з мишами - це дичина.
Людмила каже: вперше у своєму житті доводиться жити в таких умовах.
У нас завжди був свій особистий простір.
Зараз, бачте, його в нас зовсім нема.
Тобто постійно всі разом.
У тебе немає можливості побути самому.
Хіба що в душі, якій збудували з ящиків від російських боєприпасів.
Мілітарний душ.
Отакі в нас ящики зі снарядів.
Але, знаєте, влітку добре. Можеш покупатися.
Стою, купаюся, а ще генератор заведений,
у мене радіо на телефоні грає.
І я така думаю: "Ну, чому не можна так взимку?" Бо тут навіть душі не нагрієш,
не те, щоб купатися. Тут нема, як посидіти.
Я сидячи замерзала. Я всю зиму простояла біля відкритих дверцят плити.
Та росіяни позбавили подружжя не лише дому, а й справи всього життя.
До вторгнення Росії Володимир та Людмила займалися фермерством.
Загалом подружжя мало близько 120 гектарів землі.
Ми жили, будували плани,
надіялися на щось там, уже на світле майбутнє.
Адже по плану в мене було таке: до років там 50-55
достаток якийсь наживу, буду якось там працювати,
а потім я відійду від цього, передам комусь справу і буду
вже насолоджуватися своїми трудами, які до цього моменту наробив.
Нині ж відбудовує все "з нуля".
Російські військові, які перебували в селі з квітня
по вересень 2022 року, знищили майже все. А що не знищили, те вкрали.
Т-25, Т-16, Т-70, причеп, ГАЗ-73.
МТЗ вкрали, його немає, культиватори покрали,
вони нові були. Розкидачі добрив теж покрали.
Загальну суму збитків навіть страшно уявити,
каже Володимир. Йдеться про десятки мільйонів гривень.
І хоча деяку техніку фермер намагається відновити власноруч,
більшість - все ж доведеться купувати.
Причеп, який привозив добрива, розбитий.
Це я його трошки полагодив, але, як бачите, він розвалений.
Обприскувач теж розбитий, я там поставив, щоб хоч як-небудь було.
Більш-менш вцілів лише цей трактор.
Його у вербах від росіян заховав товариш Володимира - Олександр.
Я його благав, щоб він виїхав. Паразіт, не знаю…
- А він живий?
- Ні, росіяни вбили його. Він з братом, їх знайшли в погребі на сусідній вулиці.
За словами місцевих, які тут залишалися,
росіяни самі хвалилися, що його з братом у підвалі вони закидали гранатами.
Вони молоді хлопці, вони роботящі.
Загалом у Кам'янці за пів року окупації росіяни вбили тридцять дві людини.
Аби зберегти своє життя, Володимир і Людмила з села виїжджали,
а остаточно додому повернулися вже у листопаді минулого року.
На цьому подвір'ї дуже багато було боєприпасів.
"Лимонки", тротилові шашки, снаряди, гради, патрони.
Володимир розчищав подвір'я самотужки. А згодом - взявся й за поля.
Із землею в нас тут дуже критично.
Критично в тому плані, що, наприклад,
боєприпасів дуже багато валяється в нас на полях.
Я зі своїх 120 гектарів зміг тільки 28 гектарів проходити,
подивитися, винести, прийняти для себе рішення,
що я можу заїхати трактором, і це буде менше ризику для життя.
Нині подружжя готується збирати перший післяокупаційний врожай,
який вже буяє на полях.
А от заводити худобу Володимир і Людмила не поспішають.
Хоча всіх своїх корів вони втратили під час окупації.
Корова - це дорога тварина, яка потребує багато уваги,
яка дорога в обслуговуванні, скажімо так.
А тут дуже багато уламків.
Тут все всипано такими маленькими, залізними такими штучками.
Це років 10-20, поки ті уламки підуть в землю і то вони будуть із сіном...
А зараз так, що коли корова траву їстиме,
вона може проковтнути.
Корова випльовувати не вміє.
Ну, якщо їй попало в рота, то вже
99% що вона його таки проковтне, що б то не було.
Наразі на господарстві лише десяток курей,
яких подарували волонтери.
Утім, головна розрада родини - домашні улюбленці.
Покажись! Так, кота звати Бандерчик.
Це він прийшов до нас восени, таке маленьке кошенятко.
Дуже голодний. Дуже боявся, ну людей же не знав.
Нині Володимир і Людмила роблять усе можливе,
щоб встигнути звести новий будинок до зими.
А там, вірять, і до перемоги недалеко.
Задовбала! Задовбала ця війна. Хочеться скоріше перемоги.